hey what's up my name Samuel leaves and
I've got a massive treat for you today
I've just created
this is not a course this is not a
training program I kind of wish it was
it's on a book this is a game this is
property millionaire the board game and
I'll tell you something I've spent about
three years
getting this board game done and I've
just had it shipped to me from China and
I'm so excited about this game I've been
playing it again and again and again
with my wife for the last couple of days
and I've finally opened this up to the
public the good news is it's not
expensive at all I'm not trying to make
any money on this the reason I created
this board game is because I believe
that most people don't know how to
become financially independent or become
a property millionaire because they've
got no plan
they know that all the different
strategies rent to rent service
accommodation hmos buying houses deals
selling but they haven't got a plan but
the thing that this board game does so
beautiful
is once you can play this game the goal
of the game is to become a property
millionaire firstly you've got to become
financially free once you're financially
free then to become a millionaire now
if you're playing Monopoly I've been
funny right I like Monopoly I loved it
growing up as a kid but you don't learn
anything about property you know
Monopoly is kind of for losers now apart
from giving you a taste of being like Oh
I want to make money but actually if you
play Monopoly it's not even how property
Works in real life I mean Monopoly you
have to make everybody bankrupt that's
not that's not nice that's I don't want
to make anyone bankrupt that's not how
business Works in real life business in
real life works
like this this is how it works
if you
scan You'll Play it and you'll probably
you know you might win you might lose
but the more you play this game okay
you've got your little characters the
more you play this game
the quicker you're going to be able to
become financially free in the game
it's not it's not a monopoly it doesn't
take hours and hours and hours you
should be able to become financially
free in about 15 minutes in the game
and then the next goal once you become
financially free
to become a property millionaire you
should be able to do that within about
half an hour to 45 minutes
once you know in the game how to become
financially free and how to be a
millionaire
you can duplicate the exact same
strategy
and you can just do and that's why do
you know why people aren't confident in
property
it's because they're not confident
because they don't have the knowledge
they don't know where to go they know
what they're doing
if you had an exact step-by-step plan
you'd suddenly be really confident you
just do the thing pick up the phone make
the call put forward the offer when you
understand how to play this game
you know what to do in real life and I
tell you something I've spent three
years putting this together I would
never ever sell something to my audience
to my fans to my subscribers unless it
was freaking fantastic this
is a freaking fantastic board game the
investment for it I know Robert Kiyosaki
did a board game which I quite liked
cash flow 101 is kind of old now it's
not like this that's all I'm saying and
I think it costs about 100 pounds this
is 30 pounds and if you are a subscriber
of mine and you get it tonight before
midnight I'm gonna do a half price
discount you're gonna get it for 14.99
so I'm going to leave a link in the
description
14.99 It Ends Tonight and it's a fun
game you're going to be buying houses
you're going to be coming across real
life challenges you're going to be
figuring out the plan to become rich in
the game and then you're just going to
be able to go replicate it in real life
I can't wait to hear your results I
honestly think this board game is going
to help more people become financially
free than any of my books has done and I
just can't wait to see the results so
get the game I'll leave it in the link
let me know how you get on maybe you
could come in my house we could play it
together I'm going to whoop your ass
though but maybe let's make it happen
click the link get the game God bless